the jurgen experience the hormone
augmentation thing is always a little
bit of a complicated discussion but
there's so much that's happening there
right now that's really interesting like
what
well for instance um sort of back to the
topic of supplements i always say look
their behaviors are the fundamental
layer you have to do the right things
for anything for sleep for learning for
sports performance but then there's
nutrition supplementation prescription
drugs and then off-label stuff
right and so we always think about when
you hear hormones in sports you always
think
just the raw conversation about
anabolics all the band stuff
we can talk about that stuff and how it
works years ago i used to work on
androgens testosterone and its
derivatives and how it impacts brain
development and body function
fear and and also mental states but
there's a category of supplements that
are very interesting
that for most people who aren't
exploring testosterone augmentation for
sport
work very well to increase testosterone
by about 100 to 200 points
not you know 300 you know not a tripling
or anything like that
and the main ones are two substances one
is called tongat ali
oh yeah that stuff's real huh yeah oh
yeah because what happens is the
testosterone molecule
it it's basically carried in a cargo so
it can be in its free form unbound form
free testosterone and everyone says oh i
want more free testosterone
you want more but the these what are
called sex hormone binding globulins
so there's something called sex hormone
bonding globulin and albumin
they carry the testosterone molecule to
the different tissues of the body
so you don't want all your testosterone
free you want some of it bound up so
that it can be delivered to the
different tissues including your brain
but if you have too much sex hormone
bonding globulin the testosterone can't
really do
its things okay so tonga ali
about 400 milligrams per day has the
effect of raising
free testosterone and overall
testosterone by about 100 to 200 points
and so we're not talking about full trt
or blasting or now that i
i'm always amused on youtube they now
call it sports trt that's when you get
above 200 milligrams per week
sports this is basically you know you've
got trt which is
typically about 200 milligrams and we
say 200 milligrams when you're looking
at a syringe
what is that so that's is that a
thousand milligrams
so the typical dose of of uh
testosterone replacement therapy
is 200 milligrams given once every
week to two weeks but when you look at a
full syringe what is that so for one cc
one mill right that's 200 milligrams
typically of scipionate which is sold
one cc a full cc is only one cc
is not going to be that much it's it
yeah so it depends if you have a little
narrow strings
okay right right but if you have a
syringe that goes up to 10.
what is that that's 10 cc's that's
that's 10 cc yeah that's a thousand
milligrams that makes sense right so it
would be two on that and that's 200
milligrams that's right so
well okay so as long as we're going down
like two full syringes yeah i mean i
actually think that a lot of people who
think they need trt when i hear about
guys in their 20s and 30s
look i'm in my mid-40s and i can tell
you that you can
get and maintain very healthy
testosterone levels without trt if you
do the right things the behaviors the
nutrition all the other stuff
early on there's sometimes people who
have hypocrinal syndromes and things
like that there's a lot of issues with
guys that head injuries
and with head injuries and absolutely
and we it'd be an interesting
conversation to talk about the role of
testosterone in neural repair it's very
interesting
but when you look at trt i mean
the way that the clinics and the doctors
typically do it is to give 200
milligrams and then send people out for
two weeks and then they come back
because they can charge them to come
back repeatedly it's clear that
on a without any trt the testes normally
make anywhere from seven to fifteen
milligrams of testosterone per day
so taking this massive dose and then
waiting two weeks is absolutely foolish
it doesn't it's amazing to me that the
the medical profession does this because
it doesn't match anything about the
normal patterns of endocrinology
it's just not how the body works the way
it's been described to me to do it is to
do it um
with an insulin syringe and to do a tiny
amount
every three days right that's correct
yeah so 0.2 milli you know 0.2
mil so maybe you know 20 to 60
milligrams every
every few days every third day or so
that much more closely matches
the normal pattern of release and avoids
these estrogenic crashes and
a lot of problems that are that are
layered onto estrogen are actually
problems with prolactin
which is a molecule that's involved in
milk letdown and lactating women
but it actually shuts down the sexual
desire
and aggression you know when uh this is
interesting about prolactin so
this happens in brooding birds and it
happens in humans they've done this a
study published in the journal nature
which is our kind of apex journal
showed that when the husbands of
pregnant women
because of something maybe a pheromone
maybe some odor
of the pregnant woman actually increases
the man's
prolactin when they're pregnant puts
body weight on the guy
starts laying down body fat presumably
to prepare
the father for the long sleepless nights
ahead because humans have always
co-parented
wow am i mostly co-parented we
all know women do far more but it's
teachers out there who get fat don't
feel bad
yeah so that's going on the dad is is
it's part due to an increase in
prolactin
and testosterone and prolactin are kind
of working in opposite fashion
so it's a very interesting thing but the
way you describe it is correct now for
people that
aren't getting prescribed trt but want
the increase in testosterone
there are these plant compounds like
tonga ali and another one which is very
interesting it's a nigerian shrub
called phadoggia aggressis and it
mimics luteinizing hormone which is the
hormone that comes out of the
hypothalamus that stimulates the
testes if you got those and your ovaries
if you've got those to make more
testosterone
or estrogen and so those two herbal
supplements together
can give a significant boost in free and
active testosterone so you said tongue
god ali can give you 100 to 200 yeah
about that
what does the other one give you fadoja
is usually taken at about 600 milligrams
um and that can mean the most dramatic
effect i've ever seen was somebody you
had is testosterone down in the low
twos or i think it was like low twos and
it he got it up to the 700 range which
but that's it but that's an outlier
right most people are gonna see about a
three to four hundred
point increase and that's what the two
of them synergistically the dojo will
actually make the testes grow
it's a it's a noticeable difference so
everybody wants that
well the reason i know about this stuff
people are probably thinking like you
know
huberman's running gear out of the back
of his cars and that's not what this is
about is that i do
a certain amount of work with military
and i do a certain amount of work with
professional athletes who cannot take
androgen compounds out of a syringe
because they'll lose their job
right or they've been doing that and
they want to come off although and i'm
not going to out the organization
but there is one major professional
sports organization where
let's just say if somebody gets injured
they have permission to take up to 200
milligrams a week of testosterone soccer
no no [ __ ] no but good guess
you almost got me there because i almost
countered with
the actual thing that it is hockey uh no
although those guys have
the head injuries so actually say that
again right
the head injury thing is is is a serious
problem obviously so
testosterone has the effects we're all
aware of like deepening the voice facial
hair muscle growth recovery etc
mostly because testosterone increases
protein synthesis you look at a young
male in puberty
it's a protein synthesis machine yeah
they eat the aed and they just grow and
grow and grow and they're putting on
muscles and they're
lean and you know so most often they're
lean but
in any case testosterone has some very
interesting effects on the brain
the the major mental effect of
testosterone is it makes effort feel
good
oh that makes sense and the reason it
does it
is that the amygdala this fear center in
the brain this anxiety center in the
brain has
androgen receptors it has testosterone
receptors
and so the way this works in
animals and in humans as well is that
for most species the males of that
species never get a chance to mate
right so if you think about i'll
probably pick an example where you'll
you'll know the exception because i know
you know a lot about natural animals and
animals that are hunted but if you think
about animals with antlers like rams
there's been a lot of research believe
it or not on rams it'd be fun i'd love
to work on
you know rams have enormous balls and
they have to fight for the right to mate
yes and the fighting is a choice
right and the decision to walk away is a
choice usually they usually don't kill
each other although i know some of the
injuries can lead to death
so testosterone these surges in
testosterone that happen seasonally
in certain species like rams or even
these little hamsters
the males will rip each other's
testicles off in order to fight for the
right to mate
so males of a given species have to
actually overcome the fear of
pain and punishment and the surge in
testosterone
is what causes the shift to the
willingness to engage in battle
and so when humans are taking low doses
or reasonable doses of testosterone or
they're increasing their testosterone or
they're going through puberty
effort and leaning into pain and
challenge actually
has the effect of making the body feel
soothed and good
it's a drive just like sex is a drive or
drinking water when you're thirsty as a
drive
this stuff is all anchored deep within
the hypothalamus this isn't a cognitive
thing
that makes sense why young men in
particular
are really driven to hard exercise and
sports that are very very difficult that
require extreme effort
completely makes sense yeah and why when
people are testosterone depleted
they feel depressed and when people have
a surge of testosterone they feel relief
and anxiety
provided it's in the appropriate range
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background while using other apps
and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience